goodbye sir good good it's coming so he
needs a little motivation saving them up
baby don't save him too long you're
running on two holes here soon if you
keep losing them my partner's gonna make
this right
and that looked just like me trongs I
look just like you've been different in
your dreams I mean I mean I met Trevor I
mean we're both black oh did he
oh my god will that one out blue the
only explanation just as the ball mid
mid putt I just gave a little exhale
that's good I would not have been happy
you get the class I can use right now
that was a good five let it go
oh good shot this thing is gonna come
right down to the hole you didn't look
so happy with it Billy's now
oh and he's swinging a good with that
driver right now that was oily had to
withdraw from the Players Championship
and just that sets back wasn't quite
ready
there's not many people that can make a
long iron like that look as easy as he
just did but that was a really really
good shot couldn't have a better
scenario Tiger with the putter in hand
on his home course for the win that
ought to do it yeah good good I still
want to see Peyton not fit in the work
boys
great plan great job man good job tiger
it's banning the winners of Capital
One's the Nash